une légende raconte le château de
canterville serait hanté le fantôme
d'aliénor et son serviteur gwilherm
fonds fut retrouvé n'habite air koryo
cette année depuis des siècles
jusqu'au jour où bienvenue chez nous
quand vous trouvez des enfants deux mots
nouvelle famille loin du château va peut
être changer le destin du fantôme je
rentre à la maison
mais c'est ici notre maison.com
l'intimité ou pas c'est une discussion
privée là puis alors votre haleine on
met ses portes
qu'est ce qui n'arrive ne fait plus peur
toutes les publicitaires raccroche donne
l'adresse du château où vous faites quoi
vous ce soir nous apprend à faire peur
et en échange vous faites sur ma famille
la partie ne fait que commencer
mais quelle aberration
la famille canterville
un d'eux est le fantôme de canterville
m'ont complètement d'intensité avec
confondre avec le ventre il faut y
croire un peu et le 6 avril au cinéma